I don't know if you heard got a show
askgaryvee
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
welcome to the first hashtag askgaryvee
this is episode 14 26:32 47:53 6671 100
of the ask gary vee show let's get in to
the show india aaron ass actually before
we get into the show
i missed not doing the show for six or
seven days miss everybody
Big Ups to everyone a meerkat and now
India let's get into the show
Aaron ass oh wait I'm just kidding okay
yeah I'd love to give like definitive
answers to get people moving because the
more you ponder the more you squander
what and so and so and so a billion
dollars to get to you like it happens
all the time so like people value
different things I think money and
exposure are two things that actually
that are we doing Patriot stuff guys you
understand I'm a weird cut guys I'm a
weird guy I'm weird I will fire over
crazy weird [ __ ] many I'm not scared
about this I'm not scared Minnie I fire
over Patriots [ __ ] I promise hey guys
how about how do you like this know this
like that so yeah that's it let's go on
to next question on this episode I have
a guest on this episode I have two
iconic guests
and I throw a right hook for a book
that's not my own here's my real
question hey Gary I have a question for
you for askgaryvee who cares about that
question Gary this is more important
question how are you if you were the
owner of the New York Jets gonna turn
around this team and make us a Super
Bowl contender because we both know
that's all that matters and he's a
Giants fan who who gives a [ __ ] what he
has to say good I'm gonna ask myself a
question hey Gary
great show totally obsessed my favorite
thing now ahead of Game of Thrones
anyway here's a question for you if you
had a business or a blog or a personal
brand or a book how would you get more
people to to you know know about you and
to buy that tillich how would you get
results I guess at the end of the day
Gary I'm asking you how would you get
results Gary great question looking
great by the way
literally when I get an email from
somebody saying hey Gary I've got the
next big idea but I need a developer
literally immediately I go like this I
read it
I'm Chuck Mike let's let's reenact it oh
let me just catch up on my rock I'll do
that later
let me just real let me check something
else hey Gary love the show you're the
best person I've ever met did it
oh by the way I have a big time idea
except I need a developer out of
business India I'll get to that later
let me just catch up on email hey Gary
really big fan your best guy I've ever
met anyway uh the second this big time
idea but before I pitch it to you please
see the following attachment and sign
the NDA because I just can't let you see
it I don't want it stolen great delete
out of business you are out of business
which tends to be the theme of this
episode Zack can you show thanks I
thought you were hacking the show right
like you put them on knowing I would
respond to that and then get on camera I
got okay okay cool that was amazing
on this episode I answer questions in
front of hundreds of my friends
question of the day for askgaryvee four
five how many almonds are in this jar
and bad news for somebody in this room
you're gonna have to count them stuff on
your new guy somebody gets it right I
will fly you to New York City and I will
let you sit right here and be on the
askgaryvee show that is how confident I
am that the vaynernation
cannot answer this correctly don't you
tell the Vayner nation who you are one
more time and tell them what happened
first of all you guys were way closer
not being hardcore kwant
realizing you guys were gonna be able to
figure out the math you guys as a
collective scared the piss out of me
because the guesses were coming in so in
the general range the good news is
nobody won go ahead sponsor someone
didn't come close though booth slacks
came in with 423 and the countless 424
so you off about 100 you missed it by
one man one almond one almond that's
devastating a trip could have sat here
with the boys could have changed of
course your life one Amon Oh guys it
hurts that's winning and losing say with
me vaynernation cash is oxygen cash is
oxygen cash is oxygen cash come on idiot
they're with me cash they come on cash
is oxygen yes yes
this is a very special you know really
the two entrepreneurs or people that
have ever kind of over indexed to me
where Walt Disney and Vince McMahon
because they were heavy storytellers and
turned businesses out of that I like
that but to say they were my mentors you
guys are smiling okay now I'm freaked
out that eight times doing stuff just
all right I've been watching this guy
I've been watching you eight on yeah
this time this time I've got your number
uh-huh we got them this time guys we got
them I did there you want to show them
dear Rach they might be like why did he
point there is a huge Jordan I'm kidding
I'm kidding one given need like mr.
money that feels a pretty remarkable you
know I carry many I like it putting out
a picture on Instagram and holding your
breath and hoping somebody's gonna see
it cuz you use the hashtag is it enough
you know the law I believe in is that my
mom and dad had sex at a moment created
me and I'm taking this DNA to the finish
line that law that's the law I believe
in hey Michael Jerry B and I am taking
the ice bucket challenge
I challenge you
fëanor nation to step up by far the
biggest question that biggest question
the biggest thing I learned and don't
edit it
I don't edit here if I get to do like
one joke with you guys as I'm walking in
between meetings we like to find out to
be like a rare acquaintance situation
like like occurrence not acquaintance
what do you see difference what do you
see difference this is the question that
I rappelled with grappled with that's
what I keep Steve around for grammar I
would take the cloned version and I
would make that person spend every
waking moment with my family and said oh
you guys what's that why is that funny
what's that oh you know I don't care
keep this keep this keep this rolling by
the way first of all no no editing here
you know I don't think you understand
the fact that matter is is there the
same person
are you saying that Melissa maybe that
was an insight that we didn't maybe I
love my business more than my favorite
sorry it's a tough way to end the show
and the year ltb the thing that I live
on L TV the thing that I live on L TV
the thing that I live on life time value
young entrepreneur let me tell you
something from old entrepreneur which is
I love the process of the work millions
of dollars in passive income on the
internet smoking weed in Jamaica while
it just keeps coming in is just not as
real as you think partner I sell stuff
it's what I do
by this friggin rare toy it's 999 buy it
now I want to sell coffee I want to sell
cheese I want to sell wine I want to
sell gadgets I want to sell sweaters I
want to sell you if you let me that's
how I roll hustle would be putting all
your effort into achieving the goal at
hand and for me that means making every
minute count
you show me a world where all 420 of
these wonderful amazing people quit
vaynermedia and I know exactly what to
do the next day punch me in the face
8,000 times I'm here to get punched you
know my motive
comes from a couple places one I love
what I do I love the grind
I love the climb I love working I love
putting in the work I love the headaches
I love HR nightmares I love it I like it
I like the grind I like that I have a
6:30 call today with an upset customer I
like that people just not doing their
homework India I never did my homework
in school but I definitely do it in
business and I know that was black and
white because that's how we roll you can
walk
you guys aren't black and white right
now because that's how we edit do you
believe in aliens straight up like on
the record forever yes okay
you used to fun no d-roc I'm sure come
on Ian
d-roc you have to answer question who
needs that room what I do that's fine
I'm finishing my show life on the line
yes or now simple I'm showing some real
Tom Selleck stuff here
it could've warned me simple it's not
really complicated quote me too I I
think that I think the space goes way
further than our solar system what I'm
curious about and way more intrigued by
is I actually think there's another Gary
Vaynerchuk in a different world I'm so
curious of Gary in a different galaxy is
crushing it or as a user no trimming
I'm just going its until I shave it out
right it's just gonna be angry a smart
beard is coming soon oh sure sorry guys
I like you know what I like it I think I
look very fresh the other thing the
other thing that I like is through that
whole beard experiment I realized that
you can keep your facial hair at the
same exact size all the time if you want
to this is two days I think it's like
five or six days then I like the length
and I may have a permanent five o'clock
shadow for like rosro
yeah exactly he rocks it's so funny I
don't know why I didn't recognize that
you're able to do that
I literally just thought people's facial
hair just stopped and mine just kept
going and others just kept going but
like it was it's really like a very
basic thing that I just didn't
understand happened in the world
shady what up baby it's shady India
look at him in Q's outfit tonight it's
show the nation something good with that
he's got that mustard going and that
collars legit yeah the mustard all right
got that mustard brought the mustard I'm
making Scratchy's am I making scratchy
but you're not you know you don't get to
edit this either make it scratches for
you
historically since I don't eat it at
this point anymore historically I'm a
mushrooms and peppers guy Kathleen says
speaking of dating where's Nate yeah
where is it Nate let's go see where nate
is
I'm taping askgaryvee and Kathleen isn't
a meerkat I just got a notification that
Kathleen's curious where you are so here
you are why don't you give the
vaynernation you know two seconds of
what you've been Catholic Lee but what
have you been really doing today working
on budgets and scopes primarily I think
it sounds super berry riveting a lot of
spreadsheets Excel are you teaching a
young Alex the ropes so we got a scope
open right there I love it well don't
show the scope all right let's get back
to the show thanks nature well I don't
know I have to go to a thing because you
know what but I don't get it it's only
five eleven oh you want me to mingle
rabbit freaks me out super into it oh I
almost had a disaster by the way there's
fear I think there was fear on that
video you know what replay that d-roc
slowed down the fear the feel part there
was fear I know I know they saw it it's
a nasty show what is that what three
things we got a straight-up is a NASA
what is episode 96 this is nasty 96 is
nasty vaynernation Steve you humus is
such a great name I really like that
it's like Johann and Pocahontas no
seriously no huh you weren't thinking
that that's what I was thinking I was
thinking that Johan Santana that was
dating Pocahontas and they were known as
a couple as johann des
you call my reaction to that right
another squared ladies that was an al I
don't know I could see that's what got
me the ladies are we breaking periscope
I don't even know
hey what's up what's up what's up what's
up what's up what's up what's up sup sup
sup sup sup sup sup sup sup sup sup sup
sup yo yo I'm eating Jimena shall we
call the trash talk and I come back I
just it was so funny I thought I just
bought this Michael Jordan Jersey for $2
and I eat Michael Jordan but I'm gonna
do it I said sell for 40 on the bay all
right
by the way the black and white version
of this show is way better than the
stuff that goes in color I like it